Our second major area of treatment are psychological treatments. This is what a
lot of people think of when they think of a psychologist, a therapist sitting
on a couch talking to someone. Psychotherapy uses psychological techniques to
modify behavior and thought patterns, or both. And it also helps a patient
develop insight into their own behaviors. In this type of treatment, a
therapist will work with a client, either alone or in groups, and in most, but
not all of these techniques, a therapist will talk with the client. That's why
it's sometimes referred to as talk therapies. These psychotherapeutic
approaches include: psychoanalytic therapy, humanistic positive therapy,
behavioral therapy, cognitive therapy and cognitive behavioral therapy.